mccarran is continuing its rebound from  the pandemic and as more flights come to  las vegas  the airport is stepping up operations  without international travel all  14 gates at terminal 3 were closed for  more than a year  starting tomorrow morning though we'll  see the first flights use those gates  since april of 2020  half will reopen tomorrow currently only  the check-in counters have been  open passengers are checking in at  terminal 3 for some airlines and taking  the tram  to terminal 1. it's been weird to go  back and to see  those gates closed to see the states  empty and shops all shut down  no planes parked so we're really really  excited  to reopen the rest of the terminal by  the end of the year when international  travel picks up